la vingtaine c'est l'avis de tous les
projets de toutes les envies nouveau
portrait de notre série avoir 20 ans
dans les années 2020 avec qui
aujourd'hui luigi vous l'avez peut-être
déjà vu dans les rues de dijon les
livreurs pas scooter et passionné de
paris sportifs rencontre signée bamba
guèye et christophe gaillard
c'est dieu c'est dur
c'est dur d'avoir un temps en 2009 c'est
tout
salut je m'appelle l'udu rubagotti j'ai
21 ans j'avais sur dijon je suis
libraire indépendant je lis des repas de
monsieur
[Musique]
justin connecter sur l'application
et eux ils voient ma localisation là où
il ya les restaurants il m'envoie une
course après j'accepte mais on va les
coordonnées de la course je vais au
restaurant lors du prénom numéro et il
me ramène ma commande
[Musique]
c'est pas toujours la même chose que moi
j'ai toujours des nouveautés ya toujours
des scénarios tu peux pas imaginer quand
tu dis tu sais pas ce qui peut se passer
la clientèle va rigoler ça soit sera
vénère
je faisais rien je voulais trouver un
qui travaille du coup j'ai commencé en
septembre 2019
et vous dégustez juste pour faire un peu
d'argent un petit trafiquant soit un
petit job puis après ça c'est devenu un
travail à plein temps
avantage c'est de son propre patron qui
veut dire que je reçois les ordres de
personne je travaillais quand je veux
l'équipement tu dois l'acheter
d'ailleurs tu dois payer ton sac 70
euros tout neuf
le vélo ou scooter enfin à quoi tu peux
livrer si tu vas bien travaillé l'hiver
c'est sa meilleure période pas reculer t
as tu peux avoir une comme une grosse
différence
sachant
à l'hiver juste un soir je pouvais
enchaîner pendant cinq heures je pouvais
faire facilement les 70 euros
comment séduire vers
11h40 j'ai mes premières courses ensuite
j'enchaîne je vais dans les restaurants
je vécus par la commande et je vais
livrer ainsi de suite evard 14 heures ça
commence à se calmer et du coup je me
plais bien peu en ville avec d autres
livreurs on rigole puis ça sonne plus
bas je commence à rentrer vers 14h30 et
ensuite soit je suis une sieste soit je
me pose je suis un sport
soit je me pose sur mon site
[Musique]
mon site ses batteries de renault c'est
ainsi de conseils en paris sportifs
j'analyse les matchs de foot de tennis
et de basket
pour les gens qui parient j'analyse et
oui je propose un abonnement et en gros
je leur donne une analyse complète du
match avec des conseils sur quoi miser
bon matin j'espère travers mon compte
déjà et
entre parenthèses est riche enfin voilà
quoi
me faire plaisir quoi dans l'attentes
gérer mon entreprise
je sais pas j'ai pas j'ai pas de plan de
secours encore
j'essaye je mets de côté et surtout me
barrer
aller en norvège australie canada toi
c'est sûr et certain que je partirai